[Music]
I don't know I
[Music]
I don't know
I'm I'm smart feeling it today but okay
yeah my worst quality aren't too hard on
myself obviously my best and worst
quality is probably the same thing my
best qualities I'm really trustworthy
person both wrong worst qualities that I
trust people too much
is that weird like to tell I don't know
what do you think my worst quality is
probably being indecisive but I don't
know my best qualities okay wait you say
that again she's a super caring person
she'd do anything for anybody there you
go
put on the spot where Scott is this lady
calling me for it to my best quality
pretty caring person I would think for
others has snores all right my best
qualities very social very so jolly I
have my worst quality a little flaky not
always reliable my best quality would be
I love kids and working with kids and my
worst quality would be my time
management for sure my best quality
probably I work harder than anybody
[Applause]
run it constantly all there
where's Baldy I don't know where to stop
I would say the same I'm too nice
best quality
finding humor
to
initiated
I think too much yes for both my best
probably my smile what you wish but my
worse telling you have one it does only
I got I got all good fun my ability to
like get back to people or get things
done name
what do you always yell at me for I need
better patience my best quality problem
I locks my eyes probably my locks my
eyes are the Sun inside yeah what the
Sun inside means that I'm happy to live
my life with joy what you were stalling
there were very bad organic or Canada to
organizations like this my best quality
is I got the gift of gab
that's anybody what's your worst quality
stubborn
my ability to intercept you okay what's
you
I don't take my own advice
I have many knowledge uh I don't know I
guess I can make people my
what you're worth calling
I'm better hiking then my best quality
is making people laugh
making people have a good time in life
and think about the enjoyments
the negativity that can be so easily
stressed upon people and stays sunny
and what's your worst quality
I think my worst quality would probably
be on lion quickness to react to
situations rather than to assessing them
and thinking it through as much that be
modeling my negative four
[Music]
now
I don't know yet you don't know yet okay
with the worst quality awkwardness put
your best quality mmm honesty honesty
that's body good sense of humor
[Music]
a little bit too OCD attention to detail
persistence and what they're worth
quality persistence
I would say caring about people what's
your worst quality caring about people
I would say
my heart
what's your worst quality
I can be manipulative
my best quality judgment the ability to
not pass judgment on someone what's your
worst quality
attentiveness to my surroundings
attendance to my climate my atmosphere
what's your best quality
I'm resourceful I think I need to be
perfect my best quality would probably
be I'm really good at like film and
stuff like that I like to film things I
like to shoot different videos take
pictures I love stuff like that my worst
quality is my confidence definitely my
confidence
sometimes I'm not sure if my work is
good enough or not and it's really hard
sometimes to put stuff out because I
just want to put the best stuff out our
confidence just shows that sometimes my
best quality would have to be my
friendly this whatever you know people
want to want to have someone to reach
out to whether it's just for advice like
you know someone to listen to I'm always
there for my worst quality is probably a
the fact that I get in my head a lot
life and one that happens I tend to get
really insecure and I don't know like I
just get really quiet I was want to be
like you know away from everybody but I
don't know recently I've been learning
to manage that
yeah it's getting better my finished
quality um it's a tough question what am
i determining the quality of it like
something good about you
music something that's got me out of a
lot of things in my life you know
brought more I say better quality to my
inner being Who I am
there you go and what's your wish
not finishing enough I feel like that
that would be something
hopefully our
fulfill in this lifetime feeling I would
do myself a disservice with this talent
that I have but then finish what I
started
so you play an instrument or you I'm
actually an in-house producer I can pick
a get I do rap as well you can find it
on YouTube you can google striations
trea see
Nicholas where you from
I grew up in
San Diego about 14 years and with your
best quality a gift of encouragement
looking it with your worst quality
that
I am lonely
see I don't know how to talk to people I
have like social problems okay so that I
guess that's my weakness in a way I feel
like that sometimes too so I feel the
same way you doing
do you have anything else to say
I guess not really because like things
take care of themselves in a way every
like everything is kind of like
symbiotic
work out
usually they're in it
[Music]
[Music]
No